get paid right [ __ ] now yeah bring me
that check
if she says she's going on the road now
she has some dates coming up what the
baby which one you have to write no no
we have one at home and we're pregnant
she's pregnant yeah no so she's not
doing she's not gonna do a lot of dates
okay but she's a few well he did it what
but Ali's [ __ ] nuts but that he's not
always doing it like up until like seven
and a half months yeah like and also
like multiple multiple City weekends and
you know just some people do coffee I
imagine that when I get pregnant I'm
gonna be in a muumuu for six years
yeah I'm not gonna change I'm gonna have
three pairs of underwear I'm just gonna
live in a giant muumuu and I'm not gonna
move much I'm gonna stay mostly
horizontal and yeah I'm yeah I'm gonna
hug her yeah yeah but what Ali does is I
can't even fathom doing that without a
baby in my belly I mean she is she does
it with like like all systems go it's a
credible yeah she powers through it I
mean yeah I don't get it either
I'm not pregnant and I look at her
schedule my god damn I know I always
keep saying when I see how I go are you
a riot she doing good otally she's like
yeah fine fine feel great it's like what
that's the personality though cuz I have
like my older sister when she was
pregnant she was pregnant why it has two
kids she was like running they had to
tell her stop lifting weights yeah feel
great
good working out can the baby's skull
get crushed yeah come on be real certain
exercise yeah
[Music]